TO POLICE.
HE FACES FOUR COUNTS OF CRIMINAL
HOMICIDE.
>> Bret: JONATHAN SERRIE IN
TENNESSEE.
THANK YOU.
AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER, AT THIS
HOUR, PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
FIRST LADY ARE HOSTING THEIR
FIRST OFFICIAL STATE VISIT WITH
FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON
AND HIS WIFE.
WE EXPECT TO SEE THEM DO A
FOLLOW-UP FOR THE PRESS SHORTLY
JUST OUTSIDE MOUNT VERNON, HOME
OF GEORGE WASHINGTON.
BEYOND THE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE, THERE ARE SOME BIG
ISSUES FOR THE LEADERS TO
DISCUSS.
KEVIN CORKE STARTS US OFF ON
THIS VISIT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> AND HISTORIC NIGHT FOR THE
PRESIDENT AS THEY HOST THERE IS
FIRST STATE DINNER.
THAT'S TOMORROW NIGHT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AS HE MENTIONED HE WILL BE
DINING THIS EVENING AT
MOUNT VERNON, SPENDING TIME
TOGETHER.
AHEAD OF ALL THE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE, COMES A GREAT DEAL
OF CONCERN ABOUT SOME U.S.
POSITIONS AND SOME PRETTY
DELICATE INTERNATIONAL POLICY.
IN A WEEK THAT WOULD BE MARKED
BY DIPLOMACY AND MAJOR DECISIONS
BY DIPLOMACY AND MAJOR DECISION
DECISIONS.
IT'S A RETURN ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
FRENCH LEADER.
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON COMING
TO THE U.S. NINE MONTHS AFTER HE
RULED OUT THE RED CARPET FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE CHANTILLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE CHANTILLC
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE CHANTILLA
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE CHANTILLN
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE CHANTILLE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE CHANTILLY
THIS TIME THE MEN WILL DISCUSS A
HOST OF ISSUES THAT THREATEN TO
DIVIDE THE LONGTIME ALLIES.
FROM THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL TO
THE CONFLICT IN SYRIA TO WHAT TO
DO ABOUT NORTH KOREA'S NUCLEAR
AMBITIONS.
TRANSATLANTIC TRADING TERRACE,
NAFTA, THE ENVIRONMENT PART OF A
HIGH-STAKES WEEK OF DIPLOMACY
THAT WILL CEDE GERMAN CHANCELLOR
ANGELA MERKEL FOLLOW MACRON'S
VISIT TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WILL WE HAVE A GOOD
NEGOTIATOR AT THE TABLE.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE ARE TWO
LEADERS WHO HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT FOR ONE ANOTHER, A GREAT
FRIENDSHIP, BOTH HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF INTEREST IN DOING WHAT'S
BEST FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> MACRON'S VISIT CONTINUES THIS
TRADITION THAT SPANS GENERATIONS
BUT ONE THAT'S INCREASINGLY
STRAINED BY A POLITICALLY -- HIS
AMERICA FIRST AGENDA FORCING
ALLIES TO REEVALUATE THEIR
APPROACH TO TRANSATLANTIC
POLICY.
LIKE THE U.S.'S ROLE IN THE IRAN
WEIRDO.
>> WHAT IS YOUR PLAN B?
I DON'T HAVE ANY PLAN B FOR
NUCLEAR AGAINST IRAN.
>> THE FOREIGN MINISTER SAYING
HE IS CORRECT IN SAYING THERE IS
NO PLAN B.
IT'S ALL OR NOTHING.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, THE
WHITE HOUSE BRISTLED.
>> WE CERTAINLY THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A BETTER DEAL, ONE
THAT ACTUALLY IS POSITIVE, THAT
WORKS.
WE DON'T REALLY TYPICALLY LOOK
TO THE LEADERSHIP IN IRAN TO
DETERMINE WHAT OUR FOREIGN
POLICY IS.
>> POLICY EXPERTS BELIEVE MACRON
AND ANGELA MERKEL COULD COME UP
WITH ENOUGH CONCESSIONS TO KEEP
THE PRESIDENT ON BOARD.
THEY WARN THE TIME FOR EUROPEAN
LEADERS IS RUNNING OUT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT IF THE EUROPEANS
DON'T AGREE TO FIX SOME OF THE
FLAWS IN THE DEAL, THAT ON
MAY 12, HE WILL TEAR IT UP.
WE STILL HAVE A MONTH OR SO TO
GO.
I AM HOPEFUL THE UNITED STATES
AND OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES CAN COME
TO AN AGREEMENT TO CLOSE SOME
HOLES IN THE DEAL.
>> HOLES LIKE FINDING AN
AGREEMENT ON BALLISTIC MISSILES
AND INSPECTIONS AND EVEN SOME
SUNSET CLAUSES.
THERE IS RENEWED HOPE TONIGHT
HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE, BRET,
THE PERHAPS THE WHITE HOUSE CAN
BE CLOSE TO ACHIEVING SOME OF